bản phẩm qua tinh người đàn bình hộ anh yên không chăm sóu
nhằm tạo không ký buổi thư phân khởi
để nhìn dân và cạnh bụt đồ đón nơi mới
thành phói nội sẽ bố chỉ mời một chận địa bản phá hoa tầm cao
kết thược phá hoa tầm thấp và phá hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa
không em bà chận địa bản phá hoa tầm thấp
mố chận địa tầm cao sự dụng bầy chăm khỏe hoa hoa hoa hoa
hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa hoa
chận địa tầm thấp mố điểm bắn 1 chăm 2
phó hoa đúng bắn tư không dầu đến không dựng bầm phút này
mời bẩy tháng 2
năm anh yên không chăm 1 sấu tức điểm sau thừa
tổn kích phí vào khoảng gần 1 người tỉ đồng trong đó
một số chận địa sự dụng 1 sả hội hoa